[Music] emergency crews to stations get back to
Tanaka time to come here with every man he's gone
from James Bond movies to The Incredibles the
notion of secret dwellings inside mountains
has captured imaginations for decades
but 50 years ago in Scotland a power
company decided that they could use
the inside of one particular Mountain
for a very different kind of use Roxanna
saberi went to Scotland to find out more
beside the clear waters of a Scottish Lake
known as laka soars Ben crew again a mountain
rising to over three and a half thousand
feet masking a marble of engineering it
does look very James bond-ish we traveled
through a tunnel over a half a mile long
to emerge in a turbine Hall carved into rock
buzzing with Machinery this is the heart of a
hydroelectric plant that engineer Ian kinnard
says points to the future of renewable energy
8.50 gigawatts of storage energy is a maximum to
put that in context that's probably equivalent
to about 145 000 Tesla Model 3s and sitting
fully charged that's how much energy we store
who calculated that that energy comes from water
1300 feet up the mountain can you explain where
we are up here what is this absolutely in front
of you you have Crook and Reservoir which is held
back by kroken Dam Sarah Cameron who manages a
nearby Visitor Center says the reservoir fills
up with rain and water pumped up from lock off
when the water is released from the reservoir
it flows down to the power plant and through
the force of gravity turns its turbines so
it's a cycle it's a cycle exactly absolutely
when demand for energy goes up these turbines
kick into high gear within 30 seconds they
can provide enough electricity to power 800
000 homes compare that to coal-fired plants
which can take hours to spark to life the UN says
globally hydropower supplies around 17 percent of
electricity though it makes up much less in the UK
and the us some environmentalists say it's needed
to help the world transition to renewable energy
but they add dams can disrupt Wildlife the
team at crookin says it's tried to minimize
any impact by blending into the landscape as much
as possible and by using screens to prevent marine
life from being sucked from the reservoir how
well it meditate Royal inauguration a pull of
the lever and the great machines were turning
generating power for the industrial lowlands
a celebrated feat of construction that started
in 1959 it took around 4 000 workers six years
to build kruken you can still see some of the
board pools before the drilled and plastered
next year the British company Drax hopes to
begin Excavating an estimated 2 million more
tons of rock to expand the plant you know it's
Testament to those that built it back in the the
late 1950s and early 60s you know 60 years
later we're still operating this plant and
it's you know more needed than ever before they
say to help Scotland wean itself off of fossil
fuels the ready to move mountains again for CBS
Saturday morning Roxanna saberi Argyle Scotland
so cool yeah and I just say that cool and
nice last lines Roxanna I like yeah and
great great name of the town Argyle and
great accent I almost got a little lost
in the accent where I was like wait pay
attention yeah yeah very interesting yeah